salut giga je m'appelle dynastie au
platine
depuis il a lui aussi réalisé son album
et vient juste de sortir un nouveau 45
tours le temps qui passe rencontre avec
un giga disque jockey
de faire partager des musiques que
j'aime
j'achète pas des disques pour seulement
pour mon plaisir propre ma motivation la
plus importante c'est de pouvoir les
jouer à d'autres gens les faire partager
que ça soit en radio ou en tant que
disent que je quai ça c'est pour le côté
juste musical après il y a aussi le côté
technique donc c'est en voyant des
Scratchers américains il y a 10 ans que
ça m'a complètement retourné le cerveau
quoi j'ai voulu en faire autant
parce que je trouvais face à ma sauté
aux yeux comme comme quoi les platines
tout d'un coup devenait un instrument à
part entière
tout le monde aime bien passer du bon
temps et t'en profite bien car ce n'est
pas j'ai l'impression qu'il passe
vraiment très très vite et beaucoup trop
vite et qu'on n'a jamais le temps de
faire tout ce qu'on veut on a toujours
des regrets si on fait quelque chose de
pas être ailleurs à faire autre chose
etc enfin c'est la course continuelle et
je voulais faire un rap qui est un peu
explique tout ça quoi que
concours tout le temps après lui quoi on
arrive jamais à la rattraper
[Musique]
que faut-il comme matériel pour devenir
un vrai disque joker
faut deux platines comme ça c'est des
techniques c'est du sang MK2 y a que ses
platine qui existe depuis le début des
années 80 ça jamais été détrôné c'est ce
qu'il y a de vraiment de meilleur parce
que hyper rigide stable tu vois le
plateau bouge pas le bras est bien fixe
il se fait qu'on peut faire ce qu'on
veut ça saute pas quoi
il faut des cellules la lecture avant
arrière sinon le diamant il se retourne
donc ça là il y a plusieurs il y Achour
il y a Stanton chacun après c'est sa
main quoi
cette petite boîte noire c'est ce qu'on
appelle une mixette ou une petite table
de mixage on sait la CNG mini mais peu
importe la marque c'est chacun c'est les
différences de prix puis de qualité
et donc il faut qu'elle soit le plus
petit possible pour pouvoir avoir accès
facilement d'une patine à l'autre et
surtout ce qui est important c'est qu'il
y ait cette chose là qu'on appelle un
crossfader qui permet d'aller de la
patiner à la platine 2 avec un seul
avec un seul bouton
[Musique]
comme tout bon DJ qui se respecte
dynastie passe une bonne partie de son
temps à sa fontaine de vinyle chez USA
import à Paris
[Musique]
je pense que quelqu'un qui achète juste
pour son plaisir on essaie de fallait
les héroïques deviennent un peu des
samples on repère les moindres plants
qui peuvent être détournés récupérer une
petite guitare seule une pêche de cuivre
un brique de batterie des choses comme
ça qui dans ton sexe ça va nous servir
et
[Musique]
un petit bout de groove à mettre en
boucle des choses comme ça enfin moi je
note tout ça dans un coin dès que
j'achète des disques et comme ça je sais
qu'un jour si je cherche quelque chose
qui tel atmosphère je sais à peu près
quoi quoi trouver dans ce genre là quoi
aussi précieux que de l'air dans une
musique inventée par les Blacks
rencontre-tu des gens sceptiques à ton
égard
moi je suis là depuis un petit moment
donc
ça va j'ai rien à prouver et puis en
France il y a les gens qui sont dans la
musique dans ce genre de musique il y a
de toutes les couleurs
des blancs des asiatiques des noirs des
Arabes moi je pense le problème ici se
pose pas vraiment du du racisme musical
quoi on est tous dans cette musique là
et voilà quoi il y a pas de frontière
salut tout le monde bienvenue sur le
dynastie sur Radio Nova sans voix 5 pour
une heure à deux heures de purée pop
j'espère que vous êtes nombreux ce soir
derrière le poste excusez du petit
retard de 10 minutes qu'on aille ce soir
on se rattrapera en fin d'émission
dynastie est un DJ complet puisque tous
les mardis soirs il fait son émission de
radio sur Radio Nova alors si ce sujet
suscite chez vous des vocations tendez
bien l'oreille
[Musique]